thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a zany wild
ride with Stevo this week we've got Mark
Normand and he impressed the crap out of
me the guy is so just naturally a
comedian this episode's amazing and as I
speak to you right now I'm sitting in
this new Tesla Model y a seemingly empty
car which I'm gonna live in for the next
week yep that's right it seems empty but
boy is it not empty and it's gonna be
crazy night before last I uh
I tested it and sleeping in it for the
first time and my whoop band told me
that 42 of my sleep was in uh REM asleep
and deep sleep that's like insane it's
like the best night of sleep I've gotten
in ages and I would never have known
that I mean of course I felt great but I
wouldn't have known the specifics of
that without my whoop band and I'm
telling you it's my buddy Scott Randolph
the co-host of this podcast he doesn't
even wear his Apple watch anymore he
loves his whoop band so much it's all he
cares about is the whoop band it's all I
care about is the whoop band and I think
you're gonna love it just as much as me
Joe Rogan Bert Kreischer Patty the
Baddie I mean dude it's crazy it gives
you so much insight into into everything
about your health your rest your Fitness
how many calories you're burning it's
the most sophisticated tracking device
known to man and if you go to whoop.com
that's
w-h-o-oop.com and use the promo code
Stevo you're gonna get 15 off at
checkout that's 15 off of your whoop 4.0
membership and you just got to do it
you're gonna love it and so jump on this
deal whoop.com promo code Stevo 15 off
now let's get into it in general yeah I
need to definitely be with me all the
time
in general I need to have Wendy with me
all the time yeah
yeah she's your service support animal
right
um did the first time checking into a
hotel they uh they said and what task
has the dog been trained to perform
just Mobility assist what does that mean
that means I'm not [ __ ] going
anywhere without her so she gets me
where I'm going yeah
yeah Mobility assist
it's brilliant you having trouble
walking yeah you can't [ __ ] with that
it's like when a woman says it's a
feminine issue you're like you win see
you later yeah hands off here's my money
that I don't mind keeping in here we go
ladies and gentlemen Mark Norman hey
comedy boy that's a good looking [ __ ]
thank you and the dog's cute too all
right sorry yeah dude so we've never met
have we no I don't believe so right I'm
a fan thank you man likewise congrats on
all your success oh thanks I'll get
canceled eventually but right now we're
having fun I believe that there's this
thing in New York comedy where you guys
are almost like aggressively
just like trying to be over the line
well that's the weird thing is we're not
we're just doing what we think is funny
but we had Louie Gomez on tonight oh
well maybe him yeah he's he's got a
knife at your throat as a comedian but
uh I don't I just like silly stupid dick
jokes and right Asian people are weird
or whatever you know that's just funny
so yeah and then the world changed we
never changed that's the weird part the
world got all queefy and sensitive and
twittery but I'm still the same comic
you know yeah but I feel when you go to
like Portland people love it they love
it because they go they swing back
because uh they're known for being
crunchy and annoying yeah so they
overcompensate by like jizz in my ass
you know they want it hard yeah and then
when you go to Florida they're like what
the [ __ ] yeah no I don't think Florida
is an anyway sensitive at all no no no
you can wave a gun on stage like when
Michael Richards did his thing Florida
was like bring him over here well watch
that yeah he has a residency in Florida
yeah I bet he would sell out in a
heartbeat I'd go to see that I I wonder
I was just thinking about him where is
he in L.A or is he in New York he's in
La living off that pile of Seinfeld
sitcom cash yeah they just got picked up
by Netflix so they're probably doing
pretty good I wonder uh
oh The Supporting Cast did in like the
pile of cash departure oh are you
kidding me yeah come on they call it
sitcom heaven when you make it into that
uh syndication syndication yeah yeah so
and then Hulu bought it Netflix bought
it that just keeps going DVD sales
forget about it right yeah I gotta
believe that that's the case do you see
stuff come in when you get on Netflix
for Jackass or not even
um oh yeah I think so yeah for the
movies yeah we we got like a little
slippers of back-end participation so uh
when when the movie makes money we get a
little taste a little sniff oh yeah you
could tell I think it's like the older
movies it's like you know almost it's
not like funny small amounts of money
right it's not let's not like wow what
about like uh like jackass TV show isn't
that and it's indication all over the
world different deal like uh for the TV
show it was just like yeah you're a
[ __ ] we're gonna put you on TV you get
nothing you know that's the problem with
jackass though is you guys there's like
38 of you you know every time I watch
I'm like oh yeah that guy but you know
it's Steve-O bam uh Johnny Pontius you
know the the hardcore crew but there's
always a couple of was it Englert
England England yeah yeah that guy the
fat guy um Preston and his Wee Man so
there's so many of you it's like a giant
it's like the Boss Tones like how do you
guys all get a paycheck after this
concert right the boss times it so uh so
like what uh are your biggest like media
vehicles
like that that's a that's a manager
question uh one of my biggest media
Vehicles yeah I mean like like yeah
like the things that you've done that
have really launched you I would say
well that's the weird thing about the
biz now is you know I'm I'm doing comedy
16 years or so and it was all about be
funny have a good material write new
stuff and now it's like you gotta go
viral you gotta have a tick tock you
gotta have a podcast you gotta have a
sketch thing you gotta have a sitcom
idea so for me I think it was stand up
and then putting the stand up online
that's the key because The Gatekeepers
they weren't touching a lot of us for a
while so right we I put my YouTube
special on YouTube and that at the time
it was a failure like oh I couldn't get
Netflix to buy it so I put on YouTube
and it it did well and then I finally
sold tickets
oh really that's what yeah what does
more for your like being on Conan back
in the day or being on Rogan oh no
by many miles Conan's I've done nine
Conan's didn't move the needle really
right yeah one Rogan
yeah yeah that that's for sure and then
you opened for Seinfeld yeah which
that's great for me you know it's an
honor I'm a huge fan but uh that doesn't
move the needle either yeah yeah you
know Comics like hey that's cool man and
I'm like yeah my mom liked it but uh
doesn't help sell tickets it's all about
its own tickets yeah right and then you
toured with Seinfeld or did was he
mainly in like uh New York instead we
had we did four shows at the Beacon
highlight of my life best weekend ever
what's the beacon the Beacon's the big
it's our one of our big beautiful old
theaters on the upper west side okay and
that's where he always works out and so
for me to open for him there it was like
a dream it's like 3 000 seats it's
beautiful and ornate that's where he
works out that's so great oh I know it's
like the Wilbur in Boston right yeah I
like that but but no The Wilbur is way
small they're well they're like old and
Mystique yeah yeah and famous you know
like that's where uh Allman Brothers
will play or something and it's a great
theater so that was great and we had all
these dates on the books pandemic hit so
that sucked then you made a [ __ ]
Pop-Tart movie
so I haven't talked to him in a while
the uh Comedians in Cars Getting Coffee
like uh that
is insanely that that would move the
needle if you yeah that would help well
there's like eight of them and they're
all on Netflix like during the pandemic
prime time I feel oh I watched it all I
love that show Michael Richards one is
great oh shoot they address the n-word
stuff really yeah I mean you would kind
of have to yeah I feel they did it on
Curb Your Enthusiasm one of the seasons
I brought him on for the Remake and
they're like they kind of made a joke
about it right I mean you would have to
you couldn't I mean like if we had
Michael Richards on the podcast he
couldn't like dance around that no
that's a big big n-word in the room
but that's the weird thing about cancel
or whatever you want to call it is
Michael Rich did that I don't know what
was that 10 years ago it was 2006. okay
wow it was it was actually pretty
[ __ ] rare for there to be a video
camera yeah on a cell phone right right
that's what got him I think that that
the size of that file was in the
kilobytes uh yeah well it kill a bit his
career
uh yeah so the problem is like if you
murdered somebody and went to jail for
20 years and then came out you'd society
would go hey you did your time you're
rehabilitated here's a busboy job but
what he did I don't know if you can ever
shake that that's the irony about our
justice system yeah now it's like in the
hands of the people instead of like a
courtroom I wonder
um because he was like killing it in
movies wasn't he like on problem Childs
wasn't he like the bad uncle on Problem
Child UHF uh-huh he did a lot of stuff
and you don't see him at all anymore
yeah
but it's a shame
the N word it's really gnarly too like
that was just an odd way to address a
Heckler I know I know really that video
got me in a comedy yeah I don't know but
uh 16 years ago was
2006. so and and the first time I ever
tried stand-up was 2006. oh nice yeah so
how do you do you love it do you want to
keep doing it I do yeah I mean [ __ ] I uh
did the comedy club grind for 11 years
wow and uh I mean
uh all do love and respect to comedy
clubs but like when that's your deal is
here on the Comedy Club Circuit it's
pretty intense like yeah misery as far
as like a way of life goes totally two
shows a night you can hear the blender
the heckles you're in the middle of a
crowded restaurant where they're like
you know like the servers are like
you know I know it's tough dinner
theater it's a tough cake it's a tough
gig they're bringing chicken fingers out
while you're doing a setup and you're
like if you don't hear one word of the
setup you're not gonna get the punch
line right and you just gotta Buffalo
tray of buffalo wings right they
wouldn't do that during Hamilton you
know what I mean for sure that's the
hard part about comedy right so so the
comedy clubs were tough but well you
know when I got into comedy uh I just I
don't know I I loved it I saw it as a
challenge I wanted to uh you know like
prove everybody wrong somehow like I'm
gonna actually pull it off and it was
like kind of a chip on my shoulder for
years and years and years yeah you know
I'm sure it'll always be there but I've
got my own little unique approach to it
oh yeah and it goes It goes Super well
man now now I'm uh on the theater
circuit and so oh congrats yeah yeah
thank you that's a huge step up it's a
big leap to get from comedy clubs to
theaters but yeah now it's like tour bus
with my Bros and it just magically
appears where I gotta do a show and yeah
oh that's beautiful yeah I love it man
and you are different because you do
your thing up there you're still Stevo
that's right I do my thing and sometimes
my thing involves playing with poop and
there's something about poop that I
really love there's something about
pooping that I love even more when I'm
using my Squatty Potty it's the only way
to poop what is Squatty Potty well it's
this special little footstool that goes
in front of your toilet so that when
you're pooping you've got your feet
raised up puts your body in a position
that is most healthy for pooping because
think about it man as a cavemen our our
bodies were not designed to sit on a
toilet our bodies were designed to
crouch down and sit and so using The
Squatty Potty to put yourself in a
crouching position helps you have the
most complete bowel movement it's very
important to your health and I'm proud
to say that I've been a loyal user of
Squatty Potty for years before I ever
got in business with them on this
podcast actually Squatty Potty is the
one product I've been using the absolute
longest totally loyally way before I got
into business with them and man I
believe in this Theory so much about
healthy crouching pooping that before I
I got my first Squatty Potty I used to
check into hotels that had microwave
ovens unplug the microwave oven and put
it on the ground in front of the toilet
so that I could poop and use a microwave
as a Squatty Potty but Squatty Potty
itself is a much more Sleek design much
better looking and just a cooler company
man I love wearing my Squatty Potty
t-shirt it's just good fun and
everything I'm telling you is 100 true
you want to poop in a healthy way so go
to
squattypotty.com slash Devo and guess
what they're going to give you 20 off
your order man I love these people I
love this product I love these people
and I love you so I want you to be
healthy which means one more time let's
go to
squattypotty.com slash Devo for 20 off
your order thank you Squatty Potty now
let's talk more about me doing my thing
up there where's a lot of guys will get
out of movies and be like all right now
what do I do oh I'm a famous guy I'll go
be a stand-up and get some ticket money
but they're just kind of [ __ ] around
and almost taking advantage of the art
form if we're gonna be completely honest
you know like hey remember me from that
movie and here's a quote remember that
remember that but you're actually doing
a different thing
it's certainly authentic and uh every
like over the years of me doing it it
gradually uh
just my my world started converging so
so now it's like a multimedia Affair and
I'll go out and do like the the heaviest
gnarliest jackass [ __ ] yeah and then
work it into uh an act and so like after
each bit I'll pay it off with the video
of the story I told oh nice yes I I have
a lot of fun with that and it works
super well and I'm like deliberate about
filming [ __ ] that number one I could
never have done for Jackass number two I
could never [ __ ] show anywhere right
like except if I physically bring it on
the road yeah like I'm blowing loads
whoa really I literally blow a load on
camera get it up and then get it going
oh man like no no no no no no not on
stage in the in the multi
every night he's going alone
[Applause]
where I go skydiving butt naked with
another man strapped to my back and I'm
what wow seriously jacking off and
simultaneously blowing a load as I fall
out of the airplane oh that poor camera
guy yeah Jesus oh my God yeah that's why
it's like 18 and over then when like
somebody sneaks in their like 15 year
old kid you're like you get this [ __ ]
kid oh geez I can't even be ruined he's
gonna have to go skydiving to get hard
they're just so decepticized yeah you're
gonna [ __ ] his rods and cones up dude I
I I'm loving you man I love you I wish
we would have met a long time ago tell
us about what you're promoting right
here oh so me and a pal Sam Morrell we
have a podcast that I think you're doing
tomorrow or Wednesday yeah we might be
drunk so we're we feel like some of the
last Comics are still booze it up pretty
hard we have a problem and uh so we said
well why don't we get you know you got
Clooney you got Ron White you got Kevin
Hart all these guys are making that game
that that list goes longer and longer
yeah Scotty Pippen Drake like Conor
McGregor Ryan Reynolds there you go so
he said why not us it's rum did we say
The Rock
oh The Rock The Rock has Booze too he
needs another thing yeah
but this is a rye it's like a kind of
like a bullet ride but it's Bodega cat
it's made out of you know it's a New
York thing Bodega cat's like the cat
here in our bodegas that sleep on the
bread it's like a New York thing and so
uh yeah we've been selling it all all
online it's been killing it we bring it
to gigs and get a bottle
bodegaspirits.com and um and you can
yeah you can sell that online oh yeah
we're trying to get into stores with the
red tape my God these Jews and what's
that what's the alcohol volume standard
40 standard 40 and it's it's the
people's booze you know we keep it about
38.99 a bottle you know not too
expensive we added some nice whiskey
people taste it and they liked it so we
tried a bunch of different whiskeys and
we found the right one yeah why'd you
stick to Rye because I uh I quit
drinking a long time ago and my drink of
choice was uh I'd be Coors Light and old
Overholt right oh wow so I'd be
constantly sipping between that but
what's all old the old overhaul is like
a rye yeah and I always just liked it
because it's not wild turkey or rye
I think that's a width of Scotch whiskey
but I could be wrong I don't know yeah
you have a way better name than the uh
the Brendan chops whiskey what's his
called was it's like a tiger thick oh or
something like that I see he loves thick
yeah we're we're uh just Bodega we're
trying to keep it a New York Vibe so
yeah grab a bottle Bodega is very New
York yes yes and you can get it online
can't get it online in stores soon
yeah wow how long did it take you to uh
to get that going it took a while
actually we had to find the right
distributor we went with a guy out of
Houston and uh he's a comedy fan and he
knew how to Brand it and
sell it and the whole thing so we had a
lot of help
and uh now it's flying off the shelves
really oh yeah that's good because you
think you have a podcast so we have a
weekly commercial for an hour yeah with
the whiskey on it and we make drinks on
our pod that's a big big selling point
of our podcast is we've got a bartender
out there he's doing the whole
yeah yeah and and uh to peel back the
curtain a little bit you recorded this
podcast in the same place where we
currently are sitting yes in the same
building two doors down
oh so you have to go down onto the
sidewalk and over no no in this uh in
this Hall down the hallway right here
yeah yeah okay that's what I thought I
thought I saw it you'll see it on the
way to the elevator just pop your head
in and um how is that the the podcast
big ass podcast we might be drunk yeah
it's it's pretty new we're about a year
and a half or so but we got we've had
some hot guests some Bill Burrs yeah
some uh Steve O's some some uh jeez who
else Lewis Black and all these guys that
real comedy nerd Tom Papa wait we go
full on Comedy that's good Brooke right
sure you name it yeah bird crusher's the
man oh yeah do you have your own podcast
separate from that that I do well I'm a
psycho because I have another podcast
with a friend called Tuesdays with
stories and then I have my own under a
paywall
called all over the road where I go on
the road with a little lav mic and do a
whole thing where I'm in the green room
and on stage and off stage and walk
around the city oh here I am in Denver
I'm all over the road or here I am in
Phoenix and the uh the psycho fans like
to I think they like to be out with you
and they come and just and you're just
talking they don't it's all audio and we
it all goes on patreon and then we
record all the sets and put together a
little video and a montage
of that set so they get the video and we
do a comedy class so all these people
sign up and they come with their jokes
and there's like 40 of us on a zoom and
we all work out bits wow yeah wow doing
pretty well so if I hear you correctly
that means that you're doing your your
comedy sets on the road and then just
sharing them on the online yeah well I
do a thing at the end where I do a q a
because I don't want to burn material so
the crowd yells out like the queen or
black Little Mermaid and we we rip about
that and then we put that online
right that's the video they see got it
not the material because I want to do a
special right right yeah that makes
sense so that's comedy now it's this
weird oiled machine where you have to
have all these different branches of
Showbiz going on or that should be you'd
just be a stand-up you just you only
want to uh do stand up yeah like that's
the passion that's the yeah sitcoms suck
and I don't want to host a game show
like I just did Howie Mandel's podcast
and he was like hey man what you're
doing is great he's like I sold out he's
like I I I'm not a real I'm not the real
deal anymore I wanted the money so like
you guys still going for it I love it
yeah I I I appreciate his Candor my dad
my dad was good buddies with Howie
Mandel and uh oh yeah he used to go see
him do stand up because they filmed a TV
show together my dad was uh a camera
operator like in the 70s and 80s and
um one of the shows I didn't even
remember what show it was but he would
go and just uh you know see how Howie
Mandel to stand up like you know once a
week or something yeah great guy funny
guy he my dad goes ask him about the uh
the private jet in Utah and I I saw him
I didn't I didn't bring anything up but
I guess like they're all flying over to
like do it film a show and um they had
all the crew in there and the pilots let
Howie fly and so how he just got on the
wheel just went straight down and took a
nosedive and he's like he was just
laughing and everybody's freaking the
[ __ ] out but he was like yeah ask him
about that he's like he'll remember that
for sure damn what a psycho yeah she
touched the wheel that germaphobe right
that's it's crazy that uh he's so scared
of germs but would do that yeah exactly
um well that's like how most people are
like I'm scared of germs but I remember
uh I was hosting some this show Killer
Karaoke for TruTV and and they had like
uh the producers talking to me in my ear
so this the sound guys doing the
earpiece and he's like don't worry dude
the uh the earpiece is totally clean you
know like you know like like something
mentioned like Howie Mandel you know
like we we work with how to do like
don't worry the and I said oh dude don't
trip man you know like I'll make you a
deal I won't worry about what goes in my
ear you don't give me a hard time about
what comes out because my ears are
gnarly oh yeah if you look at like my uh
my
airpod oh it's like same it's just
disgusting it's orangey waxy build up
yeah I wonder how bad it is you never
get your ears cleaned and like Chinatown
or something no no you never know the
cone do you guys oh no I've seen it it's
actually pretty mellow right now yeah
that's not bad I think mine are worse
than that yeah you know it's fun though
every now and then when they get real
dirty you get the paper clip and really
clean it out and you see all the goop
and the gum that's a good time isn't it
yeah I had a bad ear growing up I had
ear infections swimmer's ear I got tubes
in my ears when I was a kid because I
had so much fluid so I'm all I'm with
you on the the earwax what do the tubes
do they suck out fluid from like deep in
the ear canal yeah did you swim or
anything like that no I think it was
just a gross piece of [ __ ] kid
yeah I think that's why jackass hits
home for so many people because you know
I grew up before the internet that's all
we did was just like kick each other in
the nuts and that was a big skateboarder
I really would chop off uh we jump off
uh apartment buildings in the pools and
then you see jackass and you're like ah
other people do this right yeah I mean
dude jumping off apartment buildings
into pools was my particular specialty
really yeah I was like a neat a niche
guy yeah yeah I was uh you know your kid
well a young boy with all this pent-up
jizz and energy and you hate your
parents and it was it was a fun release
yeah
that's uh so when Comics put
specials out on YouTube you said that
that was just like uh you know it felt
like a an L like it was like oh man you
can't sell it anywhere and now more and
more
that's like the way people are doing
it's like advertising we just talked to
TJ Miller yeah and it wasn't even like
oh he was like yeah it's on YouTube
there you go yeah that's the move now I
mean I remember Netflix said no HBO said
no and I put my heart and soul on this
thing and I was really proud of it had
you already shot it I just I I tried to
get them to shoot it and they said no
and I said I bet if we shoot it they'll
buy it because all the work is done it's
easy and I'll sell it dirt cheap and
they still said no did you uh make it to
their specs when you did shoot it
because their specs are pretty gnarly I
don't think I did I don't know I don't
know what their specs are so I guess not
so that might have hurt me as well
yeah I mean it's it's like outrageous oh
really like they're they're deliverable
what do you mean by specs though like
what do they like uh has to be shot and
like with this you know level of camera
like uh I mean dude not even like Way
Way Beyond that really and then it's
like it goes on it like they have like a
deliverable requirement sheet and it's
just like
wow oh geez I think by the I think by
the time you've uh met their
requirements like you're like 500 000 in
or something that's probably why yeah I
think I spent 15K bad boy oh my gosh
special so they said no and then Comedy
Central said we'll buy it and put on
your on our digital like we'll buy it
under our website and I was like great
I'll take it and then they turn around
and went nah you know we don't want it
so it was like a huge just boom boom
boom shot down and I just left put the
[ __ ] thing on YouTube and then I'm
gonna kill myself and whatever and then
it worked out it popped yeah thank God
that's great and and are you pretty
active on YouTube like yeah I do a video
a day like a video shorts or or a sketch
or something wow podcast clip something
just just keep it's like an IV drip you
just gotta keep feeding yeah the patient
does you also do like Tick Tock and
Instagram I do it all and I pay some
douche to do it and he's nice because I
I can't keep up I'm 38 you know I'm I'm
out of touch yeah yeah I'm old I'm gay I
got grape pubes you know so I just I
know I have to do that so this is my
work around like hey you do it I'll pay
you right I I need a social media guy
yeah it's worth it it helps yeah because
it's so shareable there are a lot of
things that I like to share and there
are also things that I do not like to
share like my personal information my
passwords my bank info I mean you name
it there's a lot of things that I like
to keep private and I get a lot of help
doing that from nordvpn that's the way
to be safe in this dangerous world of
cyber insecurity Nord VPN man it just
gives you a layer of protection that
stops people from snooping around in
your private business plus when you use
nordvpn which is a virtual private
Network you can just switch your
settings to make it like you're in any
country that you want to be in and man
has that been useful for me when I've
been traveling internationally trying to
watch the fights I don't miss a fight
I'm at UFC maniac and wherever I am in
the world I can trust that I'm watching
the fights because I have nordvpn plus
there's so much content on Netflix and
and all these other streamers that is
only available in other countries but
with nordvpn it's all available to you
and you know they got a killer deal for
the listeners of the Wild Ride podcast
if you go to
nordvpn.com
Stevo you will get a huge discount on
your plan plus four free months and it's
totally risk-free with a risk-free
30-day money-back guarantee T you can't
beat it man I have it on my phone I have
it on my iPad I use it I use it and I
just have the one account and I love it
you're gonna love it too because it
keeps you safe and it keeps you
entertained no matter where in the world
you are it's
nordvpn.com
Stevo jump on it now and let's talk
about sharing
you know some uh some guy in in Iowa
sees it and he shares his friend and
then he shares it and here we are and
now it's all over the country and people
who you you never would have tapped into
before because it's a tick tock yeah
Tick Tock and insta great yeah I mean
[ __ ] dude do you ever think about
cutting up your first special and just
cutting that all over the I I don't know
I don't have the rights to do it oh
because I uh I went in um my first
special I did with that new wave comedy
Dynamics yeah
all the oh they got you by the balls
they're old school yeah I mean I I don't
know I mean I would just
before I I chopped it up too much and
and put it out there I would uh I mean
I'm sure I could reach out to the powers
that be over there and say hey like if I
include something that says you can see
the whole special on Amazon Prime and
let this serve as promotion for it right
like I that probably work just fine
problem is that I did that first special
like arguably sooner than I should have
and uh it's tough for me to watch oh
yeah I love that there's gotta be
moments though sure I love that it it
serves as like a distinct sort of a
milestone of where I was at that time so
that the the growth since that like for
the first special to my second special
is a pretty night and day oh really yeah
and then when I get this third one out
again it's gonna be even more night and
day well in there so that's the way to
do it yeah I'm really really psyched on
that and what helped me the most is um
bringing in the multimedia component
because for my second special it was all
interstitial added after the fact so
that forced me to uh like to film my
sets bring it into the computer and edit
in the footage which really forced me to
study uh
it's tough to do that it is tough but
it's so necessary yeah it's so necessary
that that sped up my progression a lot
that I was like just forcing myself to
actually really study it and and work
with it and uh hell yeah it's just I
love the idea of you being like hey can
I can we cut up this clip of me [ __ ]
in midair and somebody's like no no we
own that that's all right and just a
midair I can't have that yeah well I
learned from my mistakes I absolutely
owned Sky Dragon oh God yeah skyjacking
the worst uh futuristic company I was as
crazy as he did they had this uh Netflix
show about like who is PJ or something
like it was like a great Skyjacker oh
really that's I didn't even know that
that was a thing
the guy that [ __ ] uh the mic Cooper
yeah DB Cooper yeah
it sounds like stealing a plane right
yeah but that's the thing that you watch
that show and they say skyjacking a
million times and I'm like oh that's
hilarious I'm like I'm a Skyjacker too
yeah it was like when when um
technically I'm a carjacker yeah when we
went to uh South Africa we were told
Johannesburg is the carjacking capital
of the world and I I don't know if we
actually got it onto the show or not but
uh we said uh you know welcome to
Johannesburg the carjacking capital of
the world and like we always say if you
can't beat them join them and you go
wide and we're just like that's great
also great they call it kidnapping and
not kidjacking
that would ruin everything
yeah yeah dude yeah for the for the next
comedy special we're uh we're gonna get
Steve some fake titties oh no that that
that's not for that's for the next hour
that I put together wait a minute for
forever permanent I mean it's gonna be
like proper surgery so that like you
know oh my God I heard about you
ostensibly it could be forever but I
will ultimately get them removed how
long do you think we're gonna keep them
in for a year the doctor that we
consulted with uh said that after three
months you're gonna have more like uh
difficulty with stretching and stuff
like yeah like keep it in for three
months or less okay it's ideal for like
being restored to normal and I think
that's long enough three months is long
enough to really produce all the bits
that will ultimately like be the tent
poles for the for the ACT wow and I
think in the in the interest of my
relationship with my fiance yeah
probably uh limiting the amount of time
that I have double D titties
that'd really helped yeah she's not like
um
she's
not not a huge fan of uh sure of my plan
to get titties not a lot of people would
be not a lot of people will I just feel
bad for the your agents other clients
you know they're like hey man you got to
pick it up out there Stevo's getting
fake tits if you haven't written a new
joke in five minutes I I believe that uh
that the act of getting like proper
breast augmentation surgery will like
generate
kind of news stories like I believe it's
gonna be like really a big news piece
which will serve to promote of course
the new tour yeah I plan to time it
um
the time the surgery like right when the
the special with skyjacking comes out
that's brilliant so yeah I think it's
gonna be like kind of uh it's also kind
of in the trans world so now you're
getting into that a little bit so right
I mean it's there's uh you're breaking
into new demographics but like you
should plan like a world tour
like of comedy with your fake titties
you got three months to do a [ __ ]
solid there is definitely
some uh
there's there's ways to take advantage
of those three months yeah yeah yeah I
can't wait to see them I want to suck
them
yeah who wouldn't want to do a meet and
greet and see some titties I know right
oh you could get a thousand dollars a
squeeze
too like I'm gonna like I will
absolutely uh I think that I'm gonna
want to start out the three months with
some nice cleanly shaven and then hairy
and then by the end of the three months
and hopefully they're just hairier than
[ __ ]
this is great oh this is so this is so
weird for me because my girlfriend uh
high school sweetheart and college
girlfriend was super into you oh wow and
so we'd watch uh Wild Wild Things wild
boys wild boys sorry and uh she was like
practically she had to sit on a towel so
this is this is weird that I feel like
if you get those tits I won yeah you
know yeah and you'll have to sit on a
towel
and you're not still with that same girl
no no that was a college girlfriend are
you in a relationship now I'm engaged
now to a lovely lady and uh you know
things are going well comedy is good
we're gonna get married how long have
you been engaged for
I don't know I guess eight months nine
months weddings next month oh wow wow
terrifying where's the honeymoon
we're thinking about uh Kenya
seriously well we're gonna go to
Johannesburg hijack
drive straight to Kenya yeah where I
want to see some giraffes God damn it I
want to get out there in safari
I mean the uh as far as a good honeymoon
you think yeah I think so okay I just
feel like I'll never go to Kenya
otherwise outside of a honeymoon so
yeah you've been to Kenya yeah what'd
you think
um romantic easy
I've been to Kenya actually uh multiple
times I went when I was a kid Oh weird
it was um my dad was the
I think he was the president of uh Del
Monte canned foods no way at least in
Europe or something what yeah dad was in
charge of a pineapple Factory and and he
had to go visit the pineapple Factory in
Kenya in Canada where they have the
pineapple oh I didn't know that yeah
they have the pineapple Factory in Kenya
so uh dad
um
timed his trip to Kenya with our spring
break at school and made it a family
vacation we went on Safari how was it it
was uh for me it was it was rather
um shocking I'd never witnessed
um like real abject poverty uh and like
you know like coming coming out of the
of the airport it was just like we were
in this car and people were like kind of
partially clothed people were clawing at
the car and kind of like getting to help
me I'll be like I I I'd never
experienced anything like that and it
was um it was it was jarring it was
upsetting especially because I I thought
of myself as a bad kid you know like I'm
just in trouble all the time I'm not a
good kid like I don't deserve to be in
the car as opposed to outside clawing at
it yeah yeah you know that was I
remember I remember that's I get this
that's my take away from it how old were
you at that time I was I think uh 11. oh
yeah it's pretty young right now you
know what we went two years in a row so
I was there when I was 10 and I was back
when I was 11. same experience uh
largely and then what about when you
went back we didn't went back for work
then we went back for wild boys and how
was that experience that um I mean I
think that the wild boys that that was
the kind of uh the the Common Thread
around the world was that wow like we
really in America we really have we have
it pretty good we really did as much as
we [ __ ] there was a lot of just poverty
around the world in the third world like
developing countries that that was uh
tough to experience and like universally
I would always kind of people would say
like where's your favorite place that
you've been and like my honest answer is
always man I'm just always glad to come
home I know I know we the reason we can
[ __ ] so much is because we have it that
good you know right we complain a lot
we're like the spoiled kid in the nice
house like I hate you mom and she's like
all I do is give you [ __ ] and he's still
mad at me right pretty much
um but the other honest answer for my
favorite place is the next place that I
haven't been yet you know like uh yeah
where you want to go what tickles yours
I've still never been to China I did
China I wasn't blown all right
I blew a guy but
how did the wall the wall was amazing
um but uh a lot of cool [ __ ] in China
that you can go do I mean that was cool
[ __ ] I I went to like Shanghai and Gung
Chu and all these places like it sounds
racist but I think that's one yeah we
did that two years ago came back with a
cough
um but yeah the tour of the laboratory I
didn't love it that much but maybe I'm
I'm weird what about other places in
Asia uh that's the only place I've been
I did the Middle East oh yeah that was
that was wild the troops so you went
there for Uso stuff yeah yeah is that
why you went to China no China was
comedy too but they had a comedy club in
Shanghai and they flew me out and all
that and so that's the only reason I
went but did you have to be careful
about the material you did it all I no
they're cool but I just did stuff that
wasn't super American was it like expats
or was it Chinese people both and the
Chinese people knew English better than
I did yeah they're just so much smarter
than us yeah they're pretty smart for
sure I wonder if it's uh illegal to play
video games in China like they're so
like about productivity and like totally
accomplishments and work and you know
like the idea of uh sitting on a sofa
whileing away and like the majority of a
day playing a video game yeah they have
three hours of tick tock they're
allotted every day that's all they're
allowed to watch no joke are you serious
yeah they don't [ __ ] around they want
you back on that cello yeah yeah the
Chinese Acrobat 10 are so rad oh I
believe it yeah the circus is killer
um are those Nigel Houston shoes they
are oh nice yeah you know about the
knives I mean I was I'm a skateboard
fanatic I skated for years I I like
these shoes I'm very particular about
um not wearing leather you know so uh
yeah I mean I'm an animal guy yeah so
the the shoes can't have suede or
leather you know anything from an animal
and um that limits my options and as far
as skatability and a vegan shoe can't
beat the 19th vegan shoe yeah that's
pretty cool yeah those look good I mean
he's amazing when I was skateboarding to
now talk about night and day like you
said it's just gone from here to here so
much you said you're uh 38 now yeah so
uh like when when was the peak of your
skateboarding I guess I was 13 14 15.
that whole I guess is like 1998 99 right
2000 so uh like Danny Way was the [ __ ]
Danny Way Jamie Thomas oh yeah
Jeff Rowley Eric costan yeah yeah big
big fan it was a bad time dude that was
a rad time in skateboarding it really
was yeah those Baker guys were wild they
won yeah day one all right 1998 was The
Birdhouse the end video yes that was
huge I have the VHS yeah and that Mouse
and welcome to hell were my favorites
yeah welcome to how I was a little older
but yeah where'd you grow up I grew up
in New Orleans
seriously yeah wow how do we not know
that uh-oh spoke the dog there
um
I don't know I don't know I should have
mentioned that earlier but yeah the
first thing I should have mentioned when
I met you guys yeah yeah
um when did you leave New Orleans uh I
started comedy and there's there's no
comedy there so you had to get out and
move so I moved here within like six
months or something so you were there
for Hurricane Katrina I was at LSU which
is Louisiana State University which is
in Baton Rouge and that's about an hour
away but my family was there the whole
thing the house was ruined and all my
friends houses got ruined it was a dark
time it has a really dark time man yeah
we've that Hurricane Katrina was in 2005
I think like maybe August or something
yeah and uh the following year like
early in the following year 2006 we shot
a bunch of Jackass number two in uh
Louisiana oh really yeah and it was just
still [ __ ]
tore up it was yeah it was it was a
gnarly why did you guys choose that
place to film then uh primarily because
we'd had such a great experience filming
wild boys there and I think that they
were just doing a lot of movie
production there because of like uh tax
breaks like uh like the Norland
Louisiana in general has been a big
destination for filmmaking oh yeah okay
more and more I worked on Benjamin
buttons as a I worked on a couple movies
in Louisiana because I was a pit yeah
because I was just a movie nerd so I was
like I'll block the street or I'll be
that guy I'll be a gopher and that was
awesome I got to see Benjamin buttons
film probably 2006 seven so it was right
after Katrina the whole city was [ __ ]
and they the movie Magic they got stuff
going they're like we need A Streetcar
and they're like well the streetcars are
out of commission they said well we can
get one working so they got one working
for the movie and you're like the city
can't do this but Hollywood can yeah I
think um that there's really a big
component too of like like
being deliberate about going to film in
Louisiana because of Hurricane Katrina
because that business is going to help
them rebuild so yeah like uh it's it's a
good thing yeah I went to the uh the
Superdome to help out like the old
people and all that and I had to help an
old guy [ __ ] and I still think about
that all the time just he pulled his
pants down and I'm like lowering him out
of the bowl and his old balls were
dangling and I had to wipe his ass yeah
it was like the first time I did
something for someone else you know what
was this for well Hurricane Katrina all
these people were like displaced yeah
but like would you you joined FEMA and
they're like well does it help other
people out this girl I was trying to
sleep with was uh helping so I was like
I'll help you there yeah so uh I only
did it for her but
I got laid Yeah it was worth it yeah it
reminds me of the story when we were
talking about with that that you helped
that guy put the kids yeah I was just
thinking about that dude listen to this
story dude it was uh I had a buddy who
was um
paraplegic
funny dude yeah oh my God we laughed so
hard with uh Travis Pastrana about this
because he was in a wheelchair and uh he
he needed help
um
putting the catheter in his in his
wiener oh God but then we but then I
realized that he'd like uh he was
paraplegic like he oh he didn't feel no
no he had the use of his hands
yeah like she's like dude you didn't
have to do that because the guy could do
it himself that's hilarious no uh here I
was I was actually holding his his
wiener with one hand and feeding the
catheter with the other hand like I was
being a great guy yeah
and uh that guy's got a hell of a story
for later you're not gonna believe it
you're the only person who's done that
where was this at
we were uh we were like going around
getting hammered in New York City as I
recall
who you and this guy yeah yeah
I I think that because I remember he had
trouble rolling up a a dollar bill to
snort coke with too
who is this guy
you met I mean I I don't need to be like
super specific about who he is but uh
yeah he's a buddy of mine
it was Stephen Hawking
yeah dude wow so uh how much are you
touring now every weekend I'm on the
road uh I got a new hour cooking I think
we're gonna sell this special thank God
I've graduated from YouTube and uh I'm
on the road just working on it tweaking
it honing it are you putting the special
on Netflix hopefully hopefully yeah
they've shown interest but uh yeah I've
been selling tickets for the first time
in my life so I'm like really
capitalizing on it nice man just did we
sold out the bray improv the Irvine
Improv so we're we're cooking
as big as Comedy Club gets all right 550
seats yeah that big ass video while I
was cute yeah killer great Club yeah
shout out to them Mikey and Brittany and
all them they're great yeah dude
likewise I uh I I love that place too is
Brittany the girl with the tattoos that
just [ __ ] people up super hot yeah yeah
super hot and then she'll like choke
somebody out like a she'll choke a dude
out just for yeah yeah I'll children she
can do to me
good time so how's La how's the scene I
mean dude I I love La man my life was an
agonizing way to get to La I'm just such
an attention [ __ ] at Heart Like that's
just where I want to be well where
where's you from originally I grew up in
five different countries like moving
around all over the world with my dad uh
when he was with Del Monte I was living
in England wow when like when I was a
little kid like he was we were in South
America yeah like we lived in Canada and
you know did you have a favorite place
growing up
yeah when I was uh we moved back to
England I was born in England we moved
uh back there when I was nine years old
and I mean I just had like crazy Freedom
nine years old like I had all the
freedom that American kids get when they
turned 16 and start driving right like
when I was nine wow there was just like
cruise around you know who you are
you're the Dos Equis guy oh yeah you're
the most interesting man in the world
and we we act like it's this old uh
Hispanic guy but it's you you lived in
England South America you're you're off
in Kenya at 11. there's uh multiple
times yeah yeah you [ __ ] every lady
you did every drug you were on the big
screen I mean you've lived man what
thank you dude I like to think that I
really truly have lived they've tested
animal products on you yeah well they've
tested drugs on me for animals
what's the difference ah that they what
I don't know like yeah yeah what was
your favorite all right well there was
only one drug that they tested on me for
use on animals
Ivermectin I know it was called rack
dopamine hydrochloride oh is that for
raccoons yeah it was to give to pigs and
cows to make them have more muscle and
less fat why wouldn't they do that on
pigs what I mean cows because the the
idea of testing it on animals was to
make the the meat leaner to appeal to a
more health conscious consumer but if it
were to pan out then the idea is that
people are gonna then eat the meat which
means a minute trace of this drug which
lives in the meat will enter the human
body and anything that comes in contact
or goes into the human body has to First
be tested right so because people would
get a trace of the drug when they ate
the meat they had to do this test to see
how much of the human body how much the
human body could withstand of the
drugs
the study went on until someone's
resting heart rate went over 150 beats
per minute
all right so was that about a gallon
that's
they uh I'm not I'm not even sure I uh I
can't really remember but um have you
ever looked this drug up since you've
done this like I I don't think it got
cleared I don't think wow I I you're the
wrong guy to test it on because you're
you're a little stronger than most there
were six people in the study and and my
resting heart rate never exactly yeah it
never went over like 90 I don't think
would anybody else oh my god there was
like one or two dudes were literally
drenched in sweat like like having like
a rough time with it and there's only
six people in the world they've tested
this drug on and you were uh in that
study I don't know if they had other
studies but yeah like normally they'll
do like the studies like a lot of people
this was a particularly dangerous study
so they had a smaller group why didn't
you have a choice the more dangerous to
study the more money you get I'm not
gonna [ __ ] around and test toothpaste I
gotta get some money
and they said okay you could do a couple
different options we have a dangerous
one and you have oh yeah and and uh it
was supposed to be for like 1200 bucks
or something and like they just didn't
get the results they were like before
they said hey we want to extend the
study and we'll bump it up from 1200
bucks to 2 000 bucks whoa you're like
[ __ ] yeah you called the place and said
how do you get the how did they put an
ad out and then you respond to it they
uh I don't know if it was an ad man I
think it was more like this one guy had
already done it and then and turned us
on to it and we called the place up and
figured it out we drove from Colorado to
Austin Texas to do it just to do that
yeah we used to do the uh the plasma do
you ever do the plasma wow did you ever
give her blow a load and sell that I
tried they wouldn't take it yeah I've
blown a load but they never yeah they
actually charged me
I tried yeah the if if you're gonna
um blow a load and have it actually be
used for artificial insemination that's
like over the top like what they pay you
by the time you get to the level of
screening and this and that they're
actually going to use it for for a donor
then like it's big money yeah like you
like anybody can go get paid like to for
them to test freezing techniques and
[ __ ] but they're not gonna well you
gotta we gotta get some little stevos
out there because I feel like you could
you could be like an army of soldiers
that wouldn't go down I love that but
I'm not interested in and I got a
vasectomy oh but we smart we saved the
sperm because I think you'd be a good
father I think so too you're a good dog
dad that was that was one of my um one
of my bits for the hour I'm touring with
now is the vasectomy Olympics
uh You Can't Get It reversed just saying
yeah that's possible I wouldn't want you
I don't think you don't want a rug Red I
do not why do you I think I'd like a kid
one day yeah I think I'd want a kid too
yeah I'm down yeah just the the world is
an unfriendly place I agree with that
increasingly unfriendly true like the
the the wealth Gap is just kind of too
gnarly I think but you're on the good
side of it yeah but I would way rather
have a lot less savings and live in a
place where everybody had dignity and
security safety
um
the idea of like the rich getting richer
and just building higher fences to keep
everybody else out like it kind of bums
me out and I don't wanna I hear you it
is a bummer but I don't know what else
to do right because everybody
you know I'd like a better world as well
but like everybody keeps moving here
like all these Venezuelans or Mexicans
and people keep coming here Guatemalans
they're like
well I guess we're better than that
place yeah right so it's kind of
confusing do you want to share you want
to stay in New York if you had a family
I do for a while I think New York's kind
of a young man's game like you see these
old fogy like some 90 year old guy
trying to get up the stairs and you're
like come on man just move to Jersey or
go go to Long Island like this is
killing you
but I don't think I would be that guy
but I would you know the next 20 years
I'd like to live here oh really so if
you had a kid like you would want to go
to the school system here I guess is it
bad I don't know oh [ __ ] I know I'll
look into it I wasn't planning on him
going to school but uh no I don't know
yeah homeschool but
I I haven't thought that far down the
line but that's this is all good good
thing about yeah you see you're a better
dad than I am we probably am both don't
have children yeah I'm uh I'm ready to
watch your [ __ ] special on YouTube
hey thanks man give it a shot I hope you
like Jew jokes yeah okay yeah it's it's
pretty heavy yeah I'm four percent
Jewish I'm gonna get offended yeah
probably well four percent of you will
yeah the uh I was four percent too but
they cut off the foreskin
I I will
um safely say that your special is
linked in the video description oh
please to uh on the YouTube version of
this podcast you just go right in the
video description and just see how
[ __ ] hilarious oh they're definitely
you're a great comic I appreciate it
yeah I work hard at it and I'll I enjoy
it so it means a lot coming from you
right on man what [ __ ] it because
like is there anything that that we can
promote other than your epic Rye with is
it right with right yeah you got it uh
go to marknormancomedy.com thanks Mark
oh it's 45 oh 45 excuse me
I'm a dig a cat yeah check it out and
they can be on your website they can
there's a link to the whiskey as well as
you should do that so Mark
normandcomedy.com that's it and that's
got your your touring you can buy all
the tickets merch everything merch
social media pages
you got it whiskey rye whiskey oh yeah
and uh yeah [ __ ] name and then yeah I
presumably you've got the the YouTube
special linked there too all their
podcasts you name it so it's it's one
click away folks yeah dude [ __ ] yeah man
dude what kind of merch do you do I just
do a t-shirt that says comedy I couldn't
think of anything they're selling pretty
well just because it's it's so vague and
Broad so people like I like comedy
yeah I couldn't think of a clever and
also you put a joke on a shirt nothing
against it but I feel like that joke's
old eventually and you're on a new joke
so the shirt is irrelevant so I like
comedy because it's Timeless yeah not
bad does it say Mark Normand anywhere on
there just a little and I got low
self-esteem so I put it tiny on the back
because I don't want to ruin the shirt
yeah with my dumb name okay
it's brilliant man yo dude I [ __ ] I
dig you man I dig you I dig your vibe
that everybody watches Special by his
[ __ ] booze follow his social media
catch him on tour hell yeah so I can
wear that comedy shirt thank you sir
it's an honor comedy
[Laughter]
he'd be more of an impressive comedian
What A rad dude
and what A rad car I was getting kind of
jealous of Scott Randolph's Tesla Model
y so I ordered one for myself and it
would appear to be totally empty but man
am I uh
not kidding when I tell you I have a
bicycle in here a full bed in here uh
like weeks worth of like all the clothes
I could possibly want to wear tons of
merch to give away Everywhere I Go
uh it's pretty insane and I'm really
excited to make a video about it so I'm
actually gonna start that video right
here and right now and I love you my
street team you're wonderful and uh it's
fun times man I hope you guys are having
as much fun as I am and thank you for
watching